hey everybody this is the first viewing
of Tom and Jerry and Willy walk in the
Chocolate Factory and sadly the first 15
minutes of footage recorded of this got
damaged when it was being imported I
looked on the camera I couldn't salvage
it but the rest of it is fine so I just
want to tell you why that's missing and
you might be wondering why my dad is in
this viewing uh he just wanted to see it
he likes commentary he likes Willy Wonka
he kind of knew he wasn't going to like
this but he just wanted to witness it so
we welcomed him aboard to make some
comments with us so that's what he's
doing here and it was an interesting one
to sit there to say the least so go
ahead and enjoy
that kid was just waiting for him to
come to the door like gara gara the
chocolate kids like sonic everything hey
please cool look at this wow look David
Lynch can make a movie out of all these
faces
no that's the element Swan Konya I am
hero man even got that shot yeah this is
going to cost vodka a fortune in
chocolate
they're already stereotypes in the
live-action version now just throw
animation on top of it it looks even
more insulting even the American kinda
look like American stereotype that's
been the easiest movie to write just
like Tommy Jerry do stuff
rip rip from original script Tommy to
redo stuff rip rip it I'm happy now
that's good fast funny droopy man
I think I was an asshole class let's
discuss how a doll can win a golden
chicken how they can work in a candy
factory let's discuss how I'm going to
take it out on you by giving you all
unnecessary apps there are you who did
see the point
what the hell what welcome the best in
the series has just been taken into
custody by people who knew JRuby was a
criminal mastermind I never thought I'd
see the day where droopy would be in
cuffs
I guess I'm already the jail bitch just
controller bringing them in to the taffy
wacky movie do you think the animators
are just trolling I'm lying here so
bored with this idea like let's at least
have fun with us I want it all
oh come on I am a dark wizard did you
give the other kids this song because it
looks like just a whisper I never
imagined so worth seeing it's like you
pink elephants and Hellfire made this
horrible combination
yeah I'm fine Johnny I'm fine look at me
that was a great segue I'm fine Charlie
Laura bad luck ha ha ha if you haven't
seen Willy Wonka at all does this work
in a lake of course not yeah I just look
at it this way if you've seen Tom and
Jerry it's better than work cuz you just
watch me Tom McGary oh no man's a
chamber pot right on top oh that's a
shitty thing to do
first it's tomorrow I'm running over
here just like the real movie is like
I've served my purpose raising this
child I get no reward end by so it's
really interesting that by word every
face looks like the last face you see
before that person eats you welcome my
friends welcome today is going to be
such an exciting day it's a computer
yeah I have been programmed to say
things welcome Jimmy oh my god what I
can't think I and a lazy I am got a lazy
pink eye and a thigh what do you get
when your glass is cracked looking like
you're having a heart attack
Oh Oh - not what I thought Charlie
Bucket will get exactly what's coming to
him I love it when I say bands are
really nice innit even away we're going
to give money to the children at the
hahaha
that all day let me so happy oh I
hope they see the oompa-loompa Queen
she's someone that squeezes out all
these a little you people don't know
about that we fell in the septic tank
but you're just the right size to fit in
my oven really all Willy Wonka is is a
harmful and gretel story where the witch
wins and recruits a new witch the Willy
Wonka story which we know so well they
haven't changed anything it's really
ironic to him singing this song about
pure imagination and changing the world
when this is one original thing
on the plane yeah what do you get with a
little rehash just a giant pile of the
movie has the time to play up all of
these characters falls this still seems
a little I feel like yeah I guess the
kid was bad mommy always liked every
second he's eating there's so little
time so these kids over I'm like wow
bunch of assholes oh my god are they
going to do the tunnel I have to see how
Tom and Jerry really want to do the
tunnel tracker all of the racially
inappropriate Tom and Jerry things in
the past all the flags mate oh come on
this is Rainbow Road a Mario Kart yeah
way of no me really yeah
no my room looks strange a more
nonsensical I wasn't averse yeah and um
know what I was expecting
oh I I'm not a lie I think I may have
just found a creepier than the arrogance
I might have to take years old kid I'm
not listening to a thing you're saying
now you just scared the out of it
you've you've lost that right okay that
banana is oh my god oh wow we
that's Little Mermaid poster man yeah
that old damn it stop it oh my god
if you licks the banana I swear to god
it sounds like maybe a look at your the
light on there couldn't they make her
really blue it's a cartoon like really
go for the fun colors they don't even
have her big enough yeah they just
stabbed her a thousand times boom baby
I'm like how does this movie deal slower
than the original it's not even an hour
and a half it's like oh my god once is
gonna end now you're just making the fan
go faster this is your lifting drink for
him no you just lost the missiles torch
shine opposite wouldn't it be amazing if
he gives Charlie the factory but then
it's revealed all the they've been
doing this mud work that's the fellow
employee of mine you know what you don't
get charlie
i order spikes all up in there what punk
you know if there's any chocolate
factory that would have them can we whip
out the paranoia here
no no your paranoia everybody coming to
get me
lost level 5a Mario World
[Music]
I want the world we're just a nose
by one
oh we've established a connection this
connects as much as Tom and Jerry and a
willy wonka movie I wonder clown soul
color okay so get down there cheery I
don't care what your smell these are
gonna burn him oh my god just going to
story three up in here wonkavision my
latest and thank god lasted on the Toria
I'm gonna take a wild guess and say this
is going to make even less sense in the
end version
Walker vision is people more could you
just not necessarily we actually had
more to that routine I don't care how
long you practice you're on the clock
now get back to work no we pay the price
for interfering with my master plan but
it's happening right now
what do you get when you don't know when
to stop we've got a pad this thing else
oh it's not quite a flop well I'll give
it this I was not predicting this is how
it ends no or they sure took a sideways
look at this thing that's one way of
putting in the section 37 of the
contract signed by him which we did not
show you didn't even put the plot point
in it that's right they fight I forgot
about yeah
hmm yes and I press them all I'll sit
for one the one that says annihilate go
on Charlie press it whoa
it's begun shot that would have been the
greater than even movie it's begun
and then just end black screen so
Charlie how did you like my factory
I fight to give it a star on Yelp oh
they got the commentary B and O it in
some ways it was not as bad as I thought
it was the best also we made it worse
because it was not even so bad it's like
memorable rage worthy bed it just bored
the living out of me and I wanted
to good slapstick moments with that it's
a little funny how bad it is at times
like the older words wrong it's like I
wanted even more funny bad
yeah when it just gets to the repeat
that is really boring I absolutely love
Willy Wonka and I love Tom and Jerry and
to see them force these two things
together and crunch them and put them
through the trash compactor and come up
with even more
that's funny we'll see you next time I
what's something good now
you